Hey there. Welcome to kube bisect, the show
where we take a look at the latest
developments in the Kubernetes master branch.
The first thing I wanna take a look
at today is some changes to the way
the logs command works.
To do that, I'll need to apply a
simple deployment,
run-in the h t t p d image,
and we're gonna have five replicas.
So we can apply this now,
and we'll just give that a few seconds
for each of those pods to quickly become
healthy.
So now we can begin to pull the
logs out from one of those pods. So
we'll just auto complete the first one
and there we go, we have some log
data.
But sometimes you wanna get logs from more
than one pod and to do that we
use the label selector.
Excellent.
But there may be a time where you
wish to use the label selector and follow
the logs and unfortunately
those flags cannot be used together.
At least that was until now.
With the latest kubectl built from the master
branch, we can use logs with a label
selector and the follow flag
to get all of our logs and stream
them in real time.
The next thing that I wanna show you
is that customize
has been built into the kube control command
itself rather than being an external third party
command.
So inside our base directory, we have another
simple deployment manifest,
And alongside that,
we also have a customization
dot YAML.
The customization YAML file allows us to modify
a single deployment for multiple environments.
Here, you can see we're specifying a namespace
and some common labels.
We also have to create a namespace itself
for the deployment to succeed.
Inside of our prod directory, we have another
customization YAML.
Only instead of setting the namespace to kubisect,
we're setting it to prod.
And just like the base directory, we also
need to create the namespace for the production
deployment,
and this is our file tree here. Nice
and simple.
Now we can use kube control master apply
using dash k instead of f to deploy
our base environment.
So this will have augmented our deployment dot
YAML with the changes on the customization dot
YAML, meaning our deployment will exist inside of
the KubeBiset
namespace.
And as well as specifying the namespace we
also requested some common labels.
If we see here the label YouTube cube
bisect was also added to our deployment.
Now if we do that apply once again,
only this time specify
the production environment,
we'll see that we created our production namespace
and we created a new deployment inside of
the prod namespace.
And just like the previous example,
our common labels were also added to the
deployment.
And that's it. Those are my two favorite
changes in the last couple of weeks to
Kubernetes master.
Until next time.